[Music]
who doesn't love paw patrol the show is
a smash hit that has fans all over the
world anything but that many fans is
bound to have some critics - you won't
believe which characters some parents
think is a supervillain in the making
stick around till number 1 to find out
if this is your first time checking out
the things smash that subscribe button
to stay in the loop that's it it's
Adventure Bay's lucky day who elected
this mayor mayor Goodway
maybe the worst elected official in
cartoon history one of the most
important functions of local leadership
is emergency management we can't help
but raise an eyebrow at a mayor who
panics so easily Ryder and his crew are
obviously awesome at solving problems as
great as they are
maybe the grown-ups of Adventure Bay
should have a plan other than a little
boy and his puppy friends it seems like
major Goodway is also the cause of most
of the problems in the Venture Bay
leaders are supposed to solve issues not
and make them it's hard not to question
the responsibility of someone who can't
even control her pet chicken chickaletta
brings a whole lot of things about the
mare into question everyone loves pets
but carrying a chicken around in your
purse seems a little unsanitary it's
more than a little questionable that
chickaletta is the deputy mayor of
Adventure Bay what are the birds
qualifications we think she was just
handed a job by her mom which is not
cool the mayor's inability to control
her chicken is one of the main reasons
the paw patrol need to come to the
rescue that not only proved that
chickaletta is a terrible deputy mayor
but it also looks bad for a good way if
she can't control a single chicken how
is she supposed to run an entire town
poor veterinary care any town that is
routinely rescued by a team of animals
must have top-of-the-line veterinarians
rights keeping animals in good health is
essential any dogs that are regularly
put into risky situations need to have a
health care team on speed-dial he would
expect Adventure Bay to have world-class
vets on standby
unfortunately chase in the game just
have katie katie is the town vet and
groomer but we're not sure where she
learned veterinarian medicine all we
ever seemed to see
Caty do is bathe dogs who handles their
routine care who gives the pups exams or
shots are the paw patrol pups
microchipped we have a lot of questions
just how old is Adventure Bay's only vet
Katie's age is never officially
mentioned but she doesn't seem to be too
much older than Ryder how could she
possibly have time to finish high school
and then become a veterinarian Marshall
rubble and the crew need a doctor they
can trust they work hard to save
Adventure Bay and provide vital services
they deserve the best health care out
there paw Patrol is all wrong
[Music]
catchphrases are out of control
catchy lines are a staple of kids TV
shows repetitive phrases help kids learn
new words and even develop routines paw
patrol takes catchphrases to a whole new
level
at the end of every briefing Ryder says
the same sentence paw Patrol is on a
roll we have to question if he really
understands the phrase on a roll maybe
you should wait until the crew has
successfully completed their mission
before he says his favorite phrase how
embarrassing would it be if they failed
does he have a rhyme for when they're
off a roll it's not enough that Ryder
has a rhyming catchphrase that makes no
sense
but each of the dogs has one - Marshall
can't help but utter I'm fired up he's
the official fire service for Adventure
Bay
we appreciate the pun but maybe he could
see more enthusiastic if he really is
fired up rubble the construction pup has
his own phrase to the police pup even
rhymes with his own name Chase is on the
case that's a lot of catchphrases for
one show you can't help but wonder how
many hours of screen time is just pops
repeating the same phrases over and over
is Marshall okay Marshall is the goofy
fire pup who always seems to have bad
luck who thought it was a good idea to
put such a clumsy dog in charge of fire
and emergency medical services for an
entire town Marshall has been known to
crash into things including other pups
does he do first-aid work on commission
is he trying to sell more gauze
we're worried about the dopey Dalmatian
it's not normal to trust a puppy to be
the fire service for an entire town if
you're going to let dogs run your
emergency services it's best not to pick
the clumsiest dog in town
is friendly and silly so he has lots of
redeeming qualities he's got his own
Twitter account and has used it to talk
about his goals fans expressed their
love of his klutzy antics when Marshall
tweeted that he was working on being
less clumsy it seems his accident-prone
personality has won over his fans and
they don't want to see it change anytime
soon
Marshall provides a lot of comedy relief
on the show he's definitely the silliest
member of the crew where are all the
girls it doesn't take much to notice the
biggest difference between the main
characters of the tenth official members
of paw patrol including Ryder and Robo
dog only two our girls Skye is the only
one who gets a regular screen time
Everest appears on occasion to provide
snow removal and be adorable it's kind
of disappointing that there's only one
girl not only does she get very little
screen time but her gadgets just aren't
as cool as the other pups the disparity
doesn't end in Adventure Bay merchandise
for the show seems to treat Everest and
Skype differently too
Skye is suspiciously absent from paw
patrol t-shirts marketed to boys that
seemed a little bit weird she's one of
the main characters why exclude her from
any merch featuring the whole team it
also seems harder to find Skye or
Everest toys Skye doesn't appear in many
paw patrol games either it's almost as
if the girl characters just aren't as
important
couple that with an incompetent female
mayor and it seems like paw patrol needs
to work on its equality we'd love to see
Skye get some cooler gear and be
featured and more boys merch too oh I'm
a bit embarrassed to report my boat is I
guess you'd say stop the captain is a
wreck the mayor isn't the only grown-up
character who seems unprepared for their
job Captain turbot may be one of the
worst ships captains we have ever seen
he has his cell phone in his hand and
nearly every scene he's in a phone is an
important tool for safety when out at
sea no one's saying he shouldn't have a
phone on the boat but maybe he shouldn't
use it while at the helm piloted his
ship is a lot of responsibility having a
distraction like a cellphone just isn't
safe the captain never seems to have any
kind of safety gear like a life vest on
either
you would think the primary
responsibility of a boat captain would
be to stay on the boat
captain turbot is either extremely
accident-prone or a swimming enthusiast
he seems to fall overboard every time he
gets on his ship the pup crew has to
save him quite frequently it seems like
there aren't any responsible or
competent adults in Adventure Bay Ryder
and his buddies have to come to the
rescue
we think any seasons ship captains
should at least be able to stay on his
boat
if you know is he's prone to falling
overboard a life vest seems like a
no-brainer
why is there so much merch it's no
secret that kids shows our goldmine for
toy companies everyone loves to play
their favorite characters and
make-believe and who can resist a
t-shirt to show off how much they love
their favorite show
we love merch as much as everyone else
does but paw Patrol takes it to another
level searching for the title of the
show on Amazon returns over 10,000
products the show is a retail powerhouse
paw patrols brought in 300 million in
sells and just one year alone the pup
happy merch doesn't end there apart from
toys and apparel there's also school
supplies personal care products snacks
and even furniture there's nothing you
can't buy with a paw patrol twist the
fans have clearly spoken they love the
hero pups merch flies off the shelves
people are ready to buy paw Patrol
certainly isn't the right fandom for
anyone who doesn't like to shop and
collects okay paw Patrol
we have an emergency who's looking after
Ryder Ryder is the mysterious
ten-year-old at the center of paw patrol
where do we even start it seems like
Ryder is on his own we never meet or
hear about his parents or any other
family does he have to have family
somewhere also who pays for his
expensive lifestyle where did a 10 year
old boy get the money to build his huge
tech-heavy control tower it's hard not
to worry about an unsupervised
ten-year-old with seemingly limitless
resources
who's in charge at his young age Ryder
should be spending most of his time in
school Ryder seems to be free all day
every day to answer the call of duty he
was handling
education he's obviously very bright he
uses quite a lot of very advanced
technology and coordinates the emergency
services for an entire town he manages
the paw patrol and saves mayor Goodway
from a lot of sticky situations that's
not easy for a ten-year-old clearly
someone is schooling and guiding him it
seems a little odd that Ryder is never
in school and seems to have no adults
around either how many 10 year olds do
you know with a robot dog that drives
them around Ryder's ego it wouldn't be
hard to argue that Ryder really is the
star of paw patrol he's the reason the
team is together in the first place he's
the one who summons the pups on the paw
pad and briefs them on their missions
some fans have speculated that he might
be the son of Ironman
the theory checks out when you consider
that Ryder is a brilliant inventor has
no shortage of funds and he really loves
his vest he also has something in common
with Tony Stark
his ego some mommy bloggers have taken
to the Internet to vent their
frustrations at a young writers attitude
it seems some parents think he has all
the makings to even become a
supervillain he lives in a huge
mysterious tower full of gadgets his
background is unknown and his parents
are nowhere to be seen
he can communicate with and control
animals it seems Ryder is one tragic
event away from becoming one of the
coolest super villains of all time maybe
the show is all about him maybe the
tragic event has already happened and
that's why we never see his parents
either way a ten-year-old taking control
of an entire town's emergency services
seems a bit off we hope you enjoyed the
10 reasons why kids shouldn't watch paw
patrol don't forget to give us a big
thumbs up and we'll see you next time
[Music]